During its remarkably consistent and lengthy
run, It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia has
brought viewers the dark and hilarious adventures
of "the gang", who never learn the typical
sitcom lessons as they amusingly make the
world a worse place.
It's an intimate, DIY affair, which makes
for a very loose set prone to improvisation.
With that in mind, here are some of the funniest
bloopers ever captured during the filming
of It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia.
In season 10, the gang undertook one of its
most notorious activities to date: attempting
to match Hall of Famer Wade Boggs' supposed
off-the-field "record."
According to lore, Boggs once drank 70 beers
during a cross-country flight.
Only Dee and Charlie make it all the way to
70 by the time their plane lands in Los Angeles,
but not without some consequences.
It turns out that drinking that much beer
is going to make even the heaviest drinker
a little gassy.
"That is disgusting."
"Give it to me.
Two.
Two."
"Oh my god!
It really is disgusting."
"It's pulled pork."
In this scene, two long-running plot threads
converge.
The first: Dennis is most likely a psychopath,
and second: the gang is frequently dismissive
of Dee, the most reasonable person in their
midst.
Dennis and Dee are twins, and yet nobody yells
at Dee with as much ferocity and venom as
Dennis.
Here, he rants about as darkly as he's ever
ranted, so offended by some minor slight.
"I will dice you into a tiny million little
pieces.
I will shove you into a box."
"I will shove you into a box, and I'll put
that box into the freezer."
The Paddy's Pub crew has tried a lot of get-rich-quick
schemes, but none are as enduring as Fight
Milk.
Charlie and Mac concocted this "alcoholic,
dairy-based protein drink for bodyguards by
bodyguards."
According to Charlie, it also, oddly, gives
consumers the strength of a crow.
Mac and Charlie try to attract interest in
Fight Milk the way the gang usually promotes
a product: with a terrible, homemade commercial.
These outtakes are from that ill-fated shoot.
"What up?!
Do you have good ideas--"
"Fight milk!...Go, three, two, fight milk!"
In the seventh season, Mac puts on a large
amount of weight.
Forever obsessed with physical fitness, he
proclaims that he's "cultivating mass," conflating
adding flabby pounds to his body with getting
muscular.
As a result, he spends a lot of his time eating
junk food, particularly in his down time,
like when he and Charlie are hanging out in
a van during a stakeout mission.
Charlie just wants to snag one chip.
"The world doesn't provide Charlie with chips
just because he wants chips, okay?
Don't care!
Don't ask again!"
One of Sunny's most popular recurring characters
is "Rickety Cricket," a former high school
classmate of the gang who went on to become
a priest, before hitting a downward spiral
of homelessness, drug addiction, and disfigurement.
This blooper comes from a scene in which Cricket
eats lemons for sustenance.
Dennis has proven himself to a be a violent,
reckless person with a deep animosity for
anything he perceives to be below his station
in life.
In this fourth season clip, he and Charlie
walk into a pretty run-down home.
Dennis immediately shows disdain by sarcastically
referring to the place as "charming" and "quaint."
Then, to emphasize his verbal eye-rolling,
he picks up a vase and throws it.
"Whoa!
This isn't a breakable vase, dude."
"Is this a joke?"
Mac was raised almost entirely by his silent,
chain-smoking mother, as his father Luther
spent Mac's whole life in prison.
Mac understandably has some daddy issues to
work through, and in a season two episode,
he tries to connect with Luther by visiting
him in the big house.
When Mac offers to do whatever he can to win
his dad's love, he asks Mac and Charlie to
smuggle heroin into the prison for him.
Mac tries to use the favor as a bargaining
chip, while Charlie gets a little over-enthusiastic.
"But if you could just give us a little advice
on how to handle this situation, I promise
we will come back our butts filled."
"Ugh!
Filled like a Christmas stocking."
Somehow, some way, Charlie gets a date in
one fifth season episode, so his friends provide
lots of advice for the big night.
For one, they specifically tell him to not
to eat any cheese, but Charlie can't help
but eat cheese when he's nervous, and, well,
being on a date makes him nervous.
Mac and Dennis find a workaround, telling
Charlie to just not breathe in the direction
of his companion, so instead he gives them
a whiff of his tremendously stinky cheese
breath.
"Just don't breathe--ugh!"
"That's it.
That's it.
Wow."